>> Jimmy: WELCOME BACK,
EVERYBODY.
IT IS TIME TO PLAY "CAN YOU
FEEL IT?"
♪ CAN YOU FEEL IT ♪
>> Jimmy: BUT FIRST, I'M GOING
TO NEED SOME HELP.
SHE STARS WITH ADAM SANDLER IN
THE NEW MOVIE, "MURDER MYSTERY
2," WHICH IS OUT ON NETFLIX
MARCH 31st.
PLEASE WELCOME
JENNIFER ANISTON!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> Jimmy: THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING -- THAT'S -- THAT'S
WHAT I'M --
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT,
A STANDING O.
>> OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
>> Jimmy: THEY LOVE YOU.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE ALL LOVE YOU.
COME ON.
>> WOW.
>> Jimmy: THAT'S A MOVIE STAR.
COME ON.
>> OH.
>> Jimmy: JENNIFER, WELCOME.
>> SORRY, I'M WALKING
BACKWARDS.
>> Jimmy: WELCOME, WELCOME,
WELCOME.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
COME ON, THEY LOVE YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME EXPLAIN THE
GAME.
HERE'S HOW THIS WORKS.
>> OH, GOD.
>> Jimmy: WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
A NUMBER OF MYSTERY OBJECTS
BROUGHT OUT TO IN FRONT OF US.
OKAY?
AND OUR JOB IS TO GUESS WHAT
EACH ONE IS.
THE CATCH IS THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT BY TOUCH ALONE.
WE DO NOT SEE WHAT WE'RE
TOUCHING.
I KNOW -- NO, I'M FREAKING OUT.
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT.
ARE YOU REALLY?
>> Jimmy: I AM.
>> YOU DO THIS -- YOU DO KNOW
WHAT'S IN EVERY ONE OF THEM.
>> Jimmy: NO, I DON'T DO THIS.
NO, I DON'T LIKE DOING THIS.
>> OKAY.
>> Jimmy: I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
YOU SAID YES TO THIS, BY THE
WAY.
>> OH, YOU --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: THIS IS SCARY.
>> WELL, DID YOU KNOW THE OTHER
THINGS THEY WANT?
NEVER MIND.
>> Jimmy: NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT, ARE YOU READY FOR
THIS?
HERE WE GO.
I WILL GO FIRST, APPARENTLY.
>> OKAY.
OH.
>> Jimmy: OH, ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE A --
THE GENTLEMAN GOES FIRST.
>> Jimmy: OH, REALLY?
YEAH, YEAH -- I'M A GENTLEMAN.
YOU CAN LOOK AND SEE WHAT IT
IS.
>> I CAN?
>> Jimmy: YES.
[ AUDIENCE OHS ]
DON'T LIE TO ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WOW.
>> Jimmy: ALL RIGHT, I'LL HAVE
30 SECONDS TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THIS IS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> Jimmy: WHAT DO YOU MEAN "OH,
MY GOD"?
WHY ARE YOU SAYING THAT LIKE
THAT?
>> I JUST DON'T THINK -- I
DON'T --
>> Jimmy: WHY, HUH?
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC ]
[ CHEERS ]
STOP.
AH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
OW.
AH, AH, AH.
♪♪
>> OH, MY GOD.
IT'S SO TERRIFYING WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO --
[ BUZZER ]
>> Jimmy: I HAVE NO IDEA.
A PINEAPPLE?
>> YOU DIDN'T EVEN MAKE --
>> Jimmy: I HAVE NO CLUE.
>> OH, WELL, I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO GUESS WHAT THAT
IS.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, CAN I JUST SHE
WHAT THIS IS?
WHAT IS THIS?
A WASP'S NEST?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
ALL RIGHT, THAT'S FRIGHTENING.
WHAT -- WHAT WAS I GOING TO
TOUCH A WASP?
>> BUT -- AND I WOULDN'T KNOW
WHAT ONE FELT LIKE, SO --
>> Jimmy: NO.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
BY THE WAY --
>> DO YOU TOUCH THEM OFTEN?
>> Jimmy: NO, NEVER, NO.
BUT THIS IS REAL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
"HI-YAH."
GET IT -- THROW IT IN THE
AUDIENCE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT WAS A REAL NEST?
>> Jimmy: NO.
JENNIFER, YOU'RE UP.
WE WOULD NEVER DO ANYTHING --
WE WOULD NEVER DO ANYTHING TO
FRIGHTEN YOU AND MAKE YOU NOT
WANT TO COME BACK.
I PROMISE.
>> OH, WHY DON'T I BELIEVE YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, NOW, HERE'S A GOOD SIGN.
THEY DIDN'T MAKE ANY SOUNDS.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> SHOULD I TAKE --
YEAH, YEAH, IT'S EASY.
THEY DIDN'T MAKE ANY SOUNDS.
THAT'S PERFECT.
♪♪
>> OH.
[ BLEEP ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SORRY.
IT'S SWEET.
IS IT SOMETHING TO EAT?
>> Jimmy: YES.
YOU CAN PICK IT UP.
>> I CAN?
[ LAUGHTER ]
IS IT BREAD?
>> Jimmy: IT IS -- NO, IT'S NOT
BREAD.
IT'S --
>> IT'S SWEET, BUT YOU CAN EAT
IT?
>> Jimmy: YOU CAN EAT IT.
>> BUT DO YOU WANT --
>> Jimmy: IT'S FRIED.
>> CHICKEN.
>> Jimmy: YES, IT'S FRIED
CHICKEN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ BELL DINGING ]
IT'S FRIED CHICKEN RIGHT THERE.
IT'S KFC.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
HERE YOU GO.
YOU HAVE A TOWEL RIGHT HERE.
SO SORRY TO GET YOU DIRTY.
>> I KNOW I COULD SMELL WAS,
KIND OF, COMING OUT.
I WAS LIKE, "I KNOW THIS SMELL,
I KNOW THIS SMELL, I KNOW --
>> Jimmy: YEAH, YOU'RE LIKE --
>> SUNDAY NIGHTS DRIVING HOME
FROM JERSEY TO GET BACK INTO
THE CITY.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> IT WAS GOOD, LIKE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING LIKE, "JIMMY -- IS THAT
JIMMY'S COLOGNE?
HE SMELLS LIKE FRIED CHICKEN."
YEAH, LIKE -- YEAH, BEFORE THE
SHOW.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT'S OKAY, I LOVE YOU FOR
IT.
>> Jimmy: ALL RIGHT, HERE WE
GO.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S BRING IN --
THIS IS MY TURN AGAIN.
YEAH, YEAH.
I DO NOT LIKE THIS GAME, BY THE
WAY.
I JUST KNOW IT GETS --
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> Jimmy: LET'S GO.
ALL RIGHT.
[ AUDIENCE OOHS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
JUST LIE TO ME!
JUST SAY THAT THERE'S NOTHING
IN HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ AUDIENCE REACTS ]
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC ]
OH, I TOUCHED MY OWN FINGER.
I GOT NERVOUS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC ]
>> YOU SHOULD KNOW THIS, RIGHT?
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: I SHOULD KNOW THIS?
>> YOU SHOULD.
I MEAN, MAYBE YOU DON'T.
>> Jimmy: IT'S --
>> BUT I THINK YOU DO.
>> Jimmy: I -- IT'S -- IT'S,
LIKE, WET.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THIS IS.
[ BUZZER ]
>> OH.
>> Jimmy: IT'S -- DO I PICK IT
UP?
>> YEAH, DON'T BE AFRAID.
JUST GRAB IT.
>> Jimmy: DON'T BE AFRAID?
>> JUST GRAB IT.
>> Jimmy: IS IT LIKE A DIAPER
OR SOMETHING?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ BELL DINGING ]
♪♪
>> BUT NOTHING REALLY WET ON
IT.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, NOTHING REALLY
BIG DEAL.
I'D WEAR THEM EVERY NIGHT, WHO
CARES.
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
YOU'RE UP AGAIN, JENNIFER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> Jimmy: YEP.
♪♪
OH, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO.
>> OH, MAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: BE CAREFUL, DON'T --
>> OH, MY GOD.
STOP.
>> Jimmy: NO, I'M NOT.
I'M NOT DOING ANYTHING.
STOP MOVING.
>> COTTON BALLS, NO.
>> Jimmy: WHAT DID YOU SAY?
>> COTTON BALLS?
>> Jimmy: I THOUGHT YOU SAID,
"HOT MOSS."
>> NO.
>> Jimmy: I'M LIKE, HOW WOULD
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS LIKE?
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
KIND OF.
>> THIS IS -- THIS IS SHEEP --
LAMB -- WHAT THIS IS?
SHEEP SKIN?
LIKE, A SHEEP?
>> Jimmy: YEAH, KIND OF.
IT IS --
>> IT'S A -- IT'S SHEARLING.
>> Jimmy: YES, YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT TO HER.
IT'S -- IT'S LINT.
>> IT'S LINT?
>> Jimmy: IT'S LINT FROM THE
DRYER.
[ BELL DINGING ]
♪♪
LIKE, A DRYER.
>> OH, NO.
OH, THAT'S NOT -- I DID NOT GET
THAT ONE.
>> Jimmy: I THINK I CAN GIVE
YOU POINTS FOR THAT ONE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I DESERVE
THAT.
>> Jimmy: ALL RIGHT, BUT HERE'S
THE DEAL.
>> OH.
>> Jimmy: IT'S TIME FOR THE
FINAL ROUND.
FOR THIS ONE, WE'RE BOTH GOING
TO AT THE SAME TIME, THE SAME
ITEM, FIRST PERSON TO GUESS IT,
WINS.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> Jimmy: SO, WE BOTH PUT OUR
HANDS IN, YEAH.
>> OH, THIS IS NICE.
THIS IS NICE.
YOU LOOK VERY SERIOUS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS GUY TAKES HIS JOB SO --
>> Jimmy: YEAH, HE REALLY DOES.
>> REAL SERIOUS.
[ AUDIENCE AWS ]
AWESOME, THOUGH.
>> Jimmy: OH, YOU'RE IN?
>> I'M IN.
[ SCREAMS ]
NO.
>> Jimmy: STOP.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO, NO.
NO.
OH.
>> Jimmy: AH!
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
[ BLEEP ]
>> WHAT?
>> Jimmy: I FELT THE HEAD.
I FELT THE HEAD.
>> FOR THAT, YOU JUST
SCARED --
>> Jimmy: IT'S A PUPPY, A
A PUPPY, A PUPPY.
>> YOU JUST SCARED ME.
>> Jimmy: IT'S A PUPPY.
>> AH!
>> Jimmy: AH!
>> I FELT A HEAD.
I FELT A HEAD.
I DID FEEL SOMETHING ROUND AND
FURRY.
>> Jimmy: SOMETHING ROUND AND
I TOUCHED IT.
IT'S A PUPPY HEAD.
>> UGH.
>> Jimmy: IT'S A PUPPY HEAD.
>> GOSH, DARN IT.
>> Jimmy: WAIT A MINUTE.
STOP, WHAT IS IT?
[ BUZZER ]
>> OH, WHAT IS IT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: THAT IS NOT FAIR, IS
IT?
[ SCREAM ]
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> Jimmy: THE EASTER BUNNY.
>> NO.
>> Jimmy: YOU ARE THE WORST.
YOU'RE AN IDIOT.
GET OUT OF HERE.
MY THANKS TO JENNIFER ANISTON.
WE'RE TALKING TO JENNIFER AFTER
THE BREAK.
I'M GOING TO GIVE JENNIFER THE
WIN ON THAT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]